think think think think think much much
welcome back to the GEMA julian podcast
for you know not your french fries
episode number 200 Wow 200 of these
first off this episode is brought to you
by the wonderful me undies the softest
underwear and the coolest underwear in
the world delivered right to your door
new designs each month three times
softer than cotton and you can get
subscription plans you can get one pair
you can get five pairs you can get 50
pairs go to meet undies comm / Gemma
Julian check it out and get 15% off your
first pair also guys if you need some
food or something from the market and
you just don't feel like getting up post
mates has got you covered
post mates is the app that provides
delivery services to establishments that
don't have delivery so you can get
restaurant food you can get takeout food
you can get fast food you can get these
literally post many of these french
fries so it's GTA guys want some french
fries yeah postmates your french fries
right now
po space is giving you $100 a free
delivery credit free for seven days to
start your free deliveries download the
app and use code Jana Julian also guys
we have a new sponsor
it is farmers dog guys this is farmers
dog as you can see it's for Kermit and
amazing okay it is a meal they make
meals for your pets and then is it is
like high quality ingredients this is no
kibble okay not for you they are not
that easy but not these who's the main
know though baby
I was dog is a company that helps dog
dogs live longer and healthier with
fresh ready to serve meals delivered
directly to your door guys
studies show that even adding fresh
fruit to your dog's diet can reduce
cancer risks by 90% also not to mention
your dogs will [ __ ] lose their mind
for this food they will love it right
now guys you can start feeding your dog
better food
going to the farmers dog that's th e FA
RM ers do g.com / annejulien you get 50%
off your two-week trial of fresh healthy
food for your pet your little baby so
check it out guys or hit the link in the
description peih-gee wants everything on
this table right now so we we thought
for kind of a while about what we wanted
to do for 200 episodes and we kind of
just came to the conclusion that we
think it'd be cool to just kind of sit
here and like talk and so right now for
you and you know what's interesting is I
feel like I feel like this episode well
it's not really a coincidence but last
night we were we were streaming on
Twitch and you know for the most part we
stream on Twitch we game and then we're
done but last night we finished our
games and we were just kind of drinking
and hanging out so we kind of just like
IRL stream for a few hours and drank and
hang out with you guys and it was very
very reminiscent about how the podcast
began in the first place which is
because that's like exactly what we did
it's like we got got some drinks we got
online and we hung out and so that was
really cool and I think it it comes
right before our second you know our
200th episode and last night we were we
were talking about the podcast we talked
about the stream we talked about
everything but um it reminded me what
that was like when we would hop on
Ustream with our laptops and then you
know well people - last night were
asking us if we would ever consider like
not like making the podcast live all the
time like maybe we start off having it
like an event you know like a Jenner
Dillion live on our twitch stream like
every once in a while yeah yeah I agree
and it wouldn't like interrupt the flow
of the podcast it's not like you're like
having callers or something that would
be a sort of drastic change it's like
you have a live chat there and we can
like you know read a couple comments and
interact in that way but to me I'm like
I'm like why would someone want to watch
this live but like I get it we get
requests for that all the time so you
know maybe in the future later in our
are late 200
episodes I think we should absolutely
figure out a way to do that my podcast
she's going nuts is there's so much food
on the table it's not for you
Saddam she can't yeah I mean last night
like we were we were it was cool because
we were having like our own
conversations and and stuff but we were
also just like sitting there and that's
like what's cool about the podcast and I
feel like you know the podcast has a
really cool thing about it because over
the years we've kind of peach stop we've
gotten to a point where you guys you
know this has become part of your
routine you like listen to the podcast
and you just want to kind of hear hear
what we have to say about whatever we're
talking about even if it's kind of like
not even really uninteresting
and so when we when we venture into
trying doing the podcast live which we
don't know exactly when it'll happen or
how often it'll happen or whatever we
just want to try it eventually and so
when we do that we're gonna do our best
to like preserve what's so great about
the podcasts but also enhance it with
live yeah but things trippy man I was
like rewatching some of our first few
episodes like not just now but like
earlier and it is wild because we like
we talk differently like we look
different everything is different we're
on our double laptops with USB mics one
of us is out of focus mm-hmm and I don't
know II we just kind of were just kind
of like all we claimed that we really
never wanted to have rules for the
podcast but at the same time we were
like trying to be like so podcast like I
was like you know I don't know I just me
were like I was sitting there like
especially when we were sitting because
we did a lot of podcast like this we
really gonna yeah and you know it's just
funny to see like us figure the whole
thing out for so many episodes but we
had a lot of really fun episodes and we
had a lot really cool guests it's crazy
thing about the guests we have because I
felt like forgot about a lot of them not
like a way that they're forgettable but
just like we had to have done somebody
else been a while yeah well and we yeah
we had I guess or a while when was the
last time we had a guest I think Kristen
said oh yeah or
yeah I think it was Kristen Shane when
we were at her old place
we don't really have a lot of guests we
don't we did we have this stretch where
we like had a lot again we had John
Cochran we had Jasmine Thompson we had
Rob Dyke we had Chris and Shannon we had
Jason and Gav's we had Gaby Gaby we had
Shane which we should [ __ ] I would be
awesome if we can get him on again cuz
he's so fun to talk to
he's a busy boy he is a busy boy he's
always welcome on this show y'all know
that but he is a busy boy yeah who else
Oh Sarah from the challenge mm-hmm try
to think we have french fries
we are french fries I drew a walk on
85th yep that's right both of them I
feel like there's more cyrus freelee the
banana girl you guys love that one chase
Harris that's my that today is my most
disliked vlog on my entire channel is
when I've logged her in our house yeah
man it's I don't know it's just while
dude I don't know that's what it is a
while that's well I'm gonna do french
fries how are you french fries as food
as cheat day I know we were this week
was crazy so we're recording on a Sunday
well we asked on Twitter like what do
you guys want us to do for our 200th
podcast because of like I feel like we
should do something special or like fun
or celebratory yeah everyone's like
doing another pizza party no you guys
literally spam the chat with the purses
like I didn't want to eat pizza today
because I wanted something else I want
french fries but like I I can't think of
any other like kids games other than the
ones that we played like hide-and-seek
and like we stacked cups and like pin
the tail on the donkey yeah I pretty
much like I pretty much Pete the
hide-and-seek game you can't really get
better than that that was the best I
could get mmm not what I got you dude I
[ __ ] got you got God you were sitting
behind me on a stepladder like a
gargoyle hell yeah dude where do you
think we'll be in our 400 podcast
I have no idea let's try to paint the
picture okay go for it okay let's think
okay so it's been four years just over
four years that we've had this podcast
it has yeah 200 episodes four years
where's the time guys this is about 50
episodes a year where has the time gone
I don't know
where's the gun it's going into these
hips boy oh [ __ ] oh he thinks I can't so
it'll be four years from now okay so
I'll be [ __ ] 35 yeah and I'll be 29
mm-hmm we'll have two kids oh won't that
be so nice you five years from now you
get to be 20 29 geez come down with that
okay I'm an old soul I'm your age right
now just a different number no you're an
Aries
okay can you [ __ ] tell them what you
said to me earlier can you please cuz
that was just something that I'll never
ever ever get out of my head oh oh let's
let's keep it like civil and cordial
here because deciding to have kids or
like figuring out if we can't have kids
yeah very intimate and all that we were
joking about having kids and I was like
sitting there in my head and I was like
hey I'm done a story she's begging for
food and she's interrupting me hey no no
I was figuring out in my head what month
we would have to conceive in order to
have an Aries baby and I was like not
know that not like I cannot have an
Aries child I can't I cannot you said
that's me while it's July I was in July
I was talking to you about something
completely separate and you like you
didn't made this blank face yeah out of
control
and you the whole time you weren't even
listen you're like okay I was just
thinking about what months we can't have
a kid and try to have a kid in I can't
have any Aries children I can't I think
it'd be fun I think you'd like it
no I hope that their little virgos and
that they they clean up after you
wouldn't criticize you did you deserve
extra Virgo energy I do want to echo
what you said though it's super personal
and well when we decided if we decide
whatever to have kids that's like
hundred percent personal so if we can
thank you for respecting I don't know if
we can thank you for respecting that
thanks for respecting my body ladies and
gentlemen cuz it belongs to me I don't
know where I was going before I got on
that tangent ladies mm I'm not hiding
your face hey by the way thank you guys
all for all the nice comments cuz I said
that people were like thank you this is
really inclusive my pleasure
what did you say that I said it on the
podcast I said it in my video maybe feel
like that makes me feel really good I'm
like [ __ ] man I wish I knew that sooner
I want to said all the time boys and
girls and Dinks beyond the binary and
yeah and well and somebody told me that
Thomas Sanders says guys and gals and
nine non-binary pals and then someone in
the comment was like how about ladies
and rows and non-binary impose amigos
sorry husband will window non-binary
hoes you know what I'm gonna enjoy my
french fries and thank you you're
welcome
mm-hmm shouts out to my non-binary hos
out there you the real MVPs all of you
what yeah hmm okay Katka one yeah we're
celebrating what rise we're having a
good time we are celebrating I hope all
your children are virgos you had a talk
into the mic for the mic to work may all
your children be for ghosts it's decided
is your punishment from flossing with
knives like I said last night I don't
care what season it is I can always do
the flossing games with knives so I can
pretty much make it Airy season anytime
that's why you can have Ares kids what
would I be like with an Ares child oh my
god the toy you would be [ __ ]
out-of-control it'd be like let's do
this now let's do that just like you're
doing the weirdest [ __ ] and I'd be
totally left out of the loop I'd be
upset and then I have to clean up the
mess you guys make afterwards it would
be really unfair are we having an
imaginary pre-emptive argument right now
yeah okay well okay let's flip the coin
then we have a Virgo kid like already in
that in the five and a half years that
I've been dating you I feel like I've
tainted I've been tamed from the inside
out mm-hmm on so many levels I feel like
I've been tamed which is good because I
didn't realize how areas I was until you
would point it out to me but if we had a
kid that was a Virgo I think I might
lose all all of the Aries about me I
think you might kill the Aries in me
then what then I'm just another then we
then we praise the Lord because we live
our lives normally but what about me and
my Flair and color and personality men
what would I do without your Flair in
color and personality you'd be bored if
by Flair and color you mean the time you
opened a banana
from the peel side like at the bottom
took the banana out and left the empty
peel on the bunch of bananas like I
don't understand that thought process I
forgot I forgot to throw it out no I
literally just the other day I walk
downstairs like you you clean you do
like chores and stuff which I deeply
appreciate but you you just have this
thing in you you're welcome whenever you
take something like if you're gonna make
a sandwich like you go and eat your
sandwich and there's every single piece
of everything that you have used to
compile the sandwich to make the
sandwich meals just everywhere I just
don't understand the like instinct to
take something out and never put it for
maximum speed when you're creating
something like a meal you get started
you get one ingredient out and then you
just gotta start stockpiling on top of
that because as like you're you're
literally gonna take double the time to
make the meal if you're running
everything back to
which when you're done eating your
hunger has subsided and you leave it all
out when you get up and you slowly put
everything no you don't do that
you don't do that I did you don't do
that so I do the know you leave stuff
out overnight on the counter and then
you wonder in the morning you're like
wow I can't eat this anymore cuz I
didn't put it back in the refrigerator I
don't mind leaving food out do you know
just the other day so he did that thing
where he was like making a smoothie or
something so there's like a bag of
frozen fruit just the left out on the
counter to turn into a ball of muck and
like the the almond milk like there's
protein powder all over the place and
there was a banana peel on the counter
and I'm just like thinking to myself
like that that's like something that a
cartoon person does they open a banana
use the banana and just throw the peel
somewhere like you were a cartoon person
I don't dude I am an exciting
high-energy very popular cartoon that's
what I am
I throw the cartoon I throw the banana
peel over my shoulder and the guy behind
me slips on it no I slip on it the guy
behind me no I'm like your personal
person that follows her on the tornado
just frantically picking up after the
tornado um okay you know they have like
simulator nut simulator like like chore
games like they have games where you can
like clean up after someone or you have
like you there's a new girl where you
unpack like after moving like those
games where you have to like stressfully
like serve like meals and do it in a
professional kitchen like things like
things like you're describing that like
cleaning up messes and stuff they
actually have games for that so if you
want to take your energy and put it
towards something constructive there
might be a game for you what you test me
in every way
and every [ __ ] way beads you test me
every day it's like having an Aries and
the carmit every day the Lord be tested
know what I'm saying
he really out here testing I'm testing
you because it's standardized testing
week I'm 31 years old what the [ __ ] are
you even talking about I'm steady for
your Julian test what comment test
what's on the test
nobody knows till it's here okay give it
back I think that the podcast has given
us a platform cut to explore how Virgo
and Aries this is like a 200 episode
long case study of virgos and Aries
having the ability to get along and cope
function dude what if what if ok I'm not
I'm not admitting that this is the real
thing
but what if Jenna and Julian was just a
bigger experiment that someone was
coordinating to observe how an Aries in
a Virgo live and work and interact
together Wow who would do that some very
very very is a [ __ ]
Virgo honestly that's really organized
mm-hmm I'm not going to confirm it
tonight that's happening what'd you just
do see what I just did there you just
cleaned up a mess that wasn't even there
you like move your hands all over the
table like you're cleaning no my drink
is like sweating a little so there's
like condensation and it's kind of wet
so I wiped it off so it doesn't destroy
the table that's good enough coasters
that's pretty weird the roast banana
peel on counter behind back alright so
the lady we got distracted 400 episodes
on our 4 host episode we're gonna have
two kids both Aries what I thought when
Aerys when love what makes you think
we're gonna have two kids in four years
in four years you're telling me that I'm
gonna basically have like Irish twins
yes sorry I'm just throwing a
scenario out here okay when's name is
Chad yes that was the one you named so
absolutely no Chad's nothing against
Chad's but no the other one's name is
one's name for god I don't know what
you're talking about I'm I'm painting
the picture of our life in four years we
have two kids
I missed a painting a picture oh the
others not even our kid it's Chad's
friend you want to leave our house so we
have Chad and Chad's friend but pretty
much have two kids because this friend
won't leave
we don't even know his name we're now
we've now moved the podcast to the
kitchen to where we just podcasts damn
it
no I why not no okay we staying here or
so this gear and all these lights in the
kitchen that's folios do you think we'll
need all this gear we're gonna be
podcasting through our brains dude we're
gonna put a chip inside our brain it's
gonna be a audio chip no a video chip
not in my body you can go into your body
I'm the guy I'll put it in my mind I
don't want that [ __ ] in my body okay
that's fine I'll trust the government
you know what I'm saying okay we don't
have to bring the government into this
we're gonna be podcasting remote of all
this gear we're not going to need all
this gears actually I really hope we
will cuz we just got it all set up that
would suck if in four years it's all
like useless [ __ ] that keep going well
how old is Chad three dude that makes no
sense
thank these four is four he's four and a
half actually
some might say or we entered a time warp
and four years is actually like 14 years
okay Chad's four I don't have a son
named Chad and I never will um it's our
daughter
I'm sorry my back okay I don't even know
how is going with us who okay new new
new discussion who are some of your
dream guests like dream guests I get too
nervous around people yeah but yeah but
like if that wasn't a factor like if
you're if you're outrageous nerves
weren't a factor
who would you dream to have on our
podcast
hi and I mean like not like [ __ ]
Rihanna
I mean we're never gonna get around
about us but like someone that is
actually a even a long shot of a
possibility to be here in our house I
think someone from the gaming community
we've really cool mm-hmm but like you
know most people don't live in Los
Angeles a lot of people ignore that no
not everybody
well not everybody cuz there's other
places I'm sorry I just won two to
nothing I think it'd be really cool to
interview somebody like shroud or like a
ninja super I think we can have some
really interesting conversations with
someone that's like sort of changing the
way that twitch or somebody that's
working because if we wouldn't just talk
about games and [ __ ] I love to talk to
the other stuff yeah if you like both I
mean I think having shroud would be
really rad but same with ninja sucks is
that they'd have to sit right here in
this little lass spot and we'd both it's
not little we can dude this okay we
scoot our chairs out hanging from his
feet from the ceiling like we talked
about last time hanging from his feet
mm-hmm and he does like spider with
mm-hmm I think it would be cool to have
a guy like shroud on or a guy like ninja
or anyone who is anyone who's pushing
the mold in in gaming right now because
like you said it's way past gaming and
right now is sort of like a really
interesting time to see where things go
choco tacos a Virgo we would have a good
time he is a very good and you would
feel left out I would be Anthony if you
brought chocolate I'll bring you
you know that's you know when he's in LA
I'm gonna invite him over I want to just
like hang on do some activities with him
like just like physical activities see
what we can muster up around the house
and like build some stuff stay out of
the kitchen no no we're gonna make some
food he likes food you guys can go out
to eat before Kuen in to get out of my
space with your Aries friend Anthony
here that I'm inviting you over for
dinner anytime dude just bring that
energy no good know what I said no okay
then Chaco can't come over and be a
Virgo Chaco I'm sorry but if there's two
burgers in the house I'm outnumbered I
can't handle that
we'll have why cuz we're too [ __ ]
logical and practical and reasonable for
you slow and by the book and reading
recipes and [ __ ] okay we'll have both if
you want it you can have your honorary
ver going on that's what we should do we
should have a podcast where you bring a
Virgo and just [ __ ] battle it out
okay what do you think on that yeah I
think they'll be fun we all sit facing
each other yeah we argue
you guys are get so [ __ ] up that we
could do things like certain tasks right
like one would have to require following
directions like maybe make like a Lego
set and we'll see which one works better
the ones that are practical and logical
or the ones that are just out of control
and they've already lost four pieces on
the ground this is a game show idea this
isn't a podcast this is like a
full-blown like this could be a whole
youtube channel or something channel I
think it could be a video no like it's
different people every week when it was
what I'm saying like so okay so we have
like a problem-solving activity we have
a speed activity we have a following
instructions activity and then we have
just like a straight-up like random wild
card one so then there's like it's kind
of balanced but then the areas will
always find a way to dominate I have a
question what do you think you are
I don't have a question okay all right
you don't really answer your question
though
dream guest yes they did oh you said
tribe yeah but dream guest like the best
guest ever would be Seth MacFarlane but
I'm too nervous to ever do something
like that I can't
Plus you'd have to come into our house
like everybody would have to come into
our house like that's so extra what is
it extra no I just feel bad being like
you don't have like a studio you're like
yeah I come to my house but like the
little ones gonna bark at you but like
try to just ignore him I'm really sorry
I mean it's but like who cares if we're
almost ooh we have a suitor in our house
dude after they dude after they come
over to podcast we'll have a playdate
that's the best part of having a podcast
in your house this is finally a built-in
playdate that's fine thank you some
people my dream guest damn I didn't
understand anything you asked is it Chad
your son your daughter looks four and a
half my dream guest would be I don't
know honestly I would have to say Jeff
Probst ah Jim we like ropes is my father
know I don't know I'm just picking
random names I'm honestly like I don't
know I think the gaming thing would be
cool anyone on Twitch would be really
cool anyone Joe Rogan in the do you
would want Joe Rogan on the pass that's
like your ultimate podcast I feel like
as long as Jamie can come and hang on I
like Jamie a lot he helped us with this
whole set up Jamie did he helped us get
our audio not sounding like [ __ ] but
Charlie might be cool but that's like it
it could never happen but it's like if
we're just but what could happen is you
going on his podcast there's the
dreamiest did you do that yes if you're
gonna be too nervous
you'd be too nervous yeah I'll get
really hot and then I get hive on my
neck you know like when I was in school
sometimes I don't get real nervous I've
got big hive like all the way down my
neck cuz that just means that I'm
nervous and people would be like are you
okay you have a hive on your neck
like no not really yeah nervous hives
I'm gonna die of hives we're not gonna
die of high dives I'm diving dying of
pipes Wow Wow
that was a lot it was just really
embarrassing like when you're in a
situation where you're not supposed to
be nervous and you just get a bunch of
hives all over your neck and like you
can just like see them appearing all up
my neck I get hives I'm gonna have some
nerves that is from Kermit but like
literally just from Kermit and allergies
what's that sorry nice
remember all the fights we stabbed on
the early podcast what kind of fights
like we didn't have us we didn't have
our like we weren't dialed in yet we
were kind of just figuring it out so I
would say I would like go off on a
tangent you'd be like we couldn't talk
about that I don't know I guess I don't
remember anything I feel like I would
read about in the comments the next day
a lot of people be like oh they're
really really not on the same page what
happens well it's also part of like a
learning curve of like any doing a
podcast to a podcast with your
significant other yeah sometimes you
just [ __ ] disagree or that's true
that's another thing that's it like
that's thing that I feel like that's one
of the things this podcast has taught me
is like being able to have a
conversation in a constructive or even
just like productive way you can just
disagree you know like nobody needs to
win an argument or whatever it's not
pointing my mic and telling me to talk
into it you you little Aries say what I
am talking about a mic I'm talking in my
mic where do you think I'm talking look
at happy 200th episode look at home what
a celebration look at how I'm talking
with your home talk lookie how I'm
talking stupid look at me now look back
at you now look at me
I'm the horse like those old space I
know what it is
I know what it is no I tried to pull the
arm closer to Me's and you told me to be
careful of my water which is closed and
sealed and isn't gonna knock over and
then you told me to talk closer in my
mind oh I miss the days when you used to
just adjust my mic for me like a hundred
times or adjust your mic a hundred times
I really people would always talk about
that in the comments stop touching the
mic okay nothing why are you looking at
me like that
nothing I'm just thinking about some
things like what just how comfortable I
am in my me and ease me and ease calm /
annejulien
well I'm not the worst that'll just be a
foster I'll do another one later
keep talking what are you doing I'm
putting my foot on you know for us but
it feels good okay I have an interesting
thought what would you ever do one of
those DNA tests no why not because I
don't like the conspiracies around it
what's the conspiracy you know what they
are what are their keeping your DNA they
like clone you yeah well that kind of
thing didn't she talk about one of his
videos that he did a good job explaining
it I usually but it's basically that you
know they have all these youtubers
promoting inches so they're they're they
basically in all of their terms of use
and services or whatever like are really
very unclear about what they have
control over and don't have control over
like in terms of your DNA like if they
can sell it to whatever the [ __ ] they
want like they're unclear about what
they're allowed to do yeah so there's a
theory that they're gonna sell it to
like your data to like drug companies
and then they can use that information
to formulate drugs for people and you
know charge top dollar for that there's
another one that they're trying to
create some type of like anti-aging
thing from that so then by the time
you're 60 years old they're like hey
here's your DNA from when you were 17 if
you'd like to buy it back from us and
you know then you become like 17 again
yeah like a looks like that sounds good
why would you why would you argue with
that I don't think I would ever want to
look 17 again huh that's a movie did you
know that exact guy fraud they filmed it
at my high school sorry no okay and the
other one that's really weird is that
like nothing against Mormons or Mormon
people but they all like a lot of those
companies are owned by more
and there is a theory it's not my theory
that they are using your DNA that even
after you die you can be adopted into
the Mormon faith correct me if I'm wrong
but that's the theory and so that they
just want to you know save everyone with
their DNA that's creepy
to think that like after you die you're
gonna be like admitted not admitted but
like taken into a religion that you
never really yeah like who I'd say
that's like you know the least of the
least of what you would have to worry
about those things but it is kind of
weird but wouldn't you be interested in
like knowing about like your DNA and
like what you know you know what your
lineage is and maybe what you're you're
one of what they think some of your
characteristics might be based on your
DNA no I believe my parents when they
say that we're mostly European and
that's about it I'm cool I don't need to
know everything I would consider it I
don't know if I would do it but I would
definitely think about why maybe it's
did you do some more research and then I
might just and then I might just get my
DNA didn't they use it like one of those
DNA kits like someone's relative abused
it and then they found the golden state
killer or whatever by using not
information so--but so someone so the
killer's relative used that DNA kit yeah
because it's not just whoever you know
uses it it's all the people that you're
related to yeah so feasibly like you
should probably get your family's
opinion or approval before you do
something like that that's what I think
yeah like cuz what if what if I were to
just like hey here's my DNA and then
like one of my cousins was like yo dude
I'm on the lam here why'd you do that
but it's it's not the concept of like
using it to solve crimes it's like the
government now has access to your
personal DNA like we don't know what
they're gonna do with it like there's a
reason why you have checks and balances
and how much information the government
can have of yours it's incredibly creepy
that's the whole privacy conversation
about like how much is too much how much
is legal and how much is like incredibly
invasive and DNA is sort of like the
last thing that you truly have that's
yours your body your genetic code and if
you sort of just so
to some company that doesn't really tell
you exactly what they're gonna do with
it in the future you know you've given
away your one sacred thing that you have
control over that's what I think I I
mean I agree with you a lot that it's
like super suss and then also the fact
that to assess well and also the fact
that they their target demo was like a
youtubers and like they were doing brand
deals and they were like sponsored the
yeah like there was a 23andme kit will
retain ball which is like so they
sponsored this show but I had already
known about 23 meters because I've seen
their name on like YouTube like brand
deals before I think I've seen people
post pictures I've seen people post
videos and I've always liked they're
always like kind of ambiguous looking
media and you're like what are they
advertising and then it's like a DNA can
you're like what what the [ __ ] like
that's so bizarre and it's so like it's
troubling to me that that's the market
they go after these are so many young
viewers on YouTube who might just be
like whoa because I mean I don't know
well here's the thing so I don't I feel
like I don't have any problem with the
alright where someone's gonna take a
sample of your blood or your spit your
DNA and we're gonna give you an
assessment of your your health risks or
your you know that kind of thing like I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that or do I think there's anything
wrong with understanding your lineage
like all that's really cool it's just
that the companies and like the wording
of what they're gonna do with it
sounds pretty - it's like yay capitalism
we got something we're not gonna tell
you what we gonna do with it but we
either go and make a lot of money with
it someday or we gonna be just [ __ ]
corrupt what do you think would happen
if a company came out and was like we're
not gonna tell you we're gonna do it
like even more like bleak in how they
stated it like we're not gonna tell you
what the [ __ ] we did with your DNA but
we'll pay you a thousand dollars to give
it to us that's terrifying like that
that to me is like the next level of
this because right now they're like yeah
by our kid it's a good price and look at
this like happy good-looking youtuber
they're also advertising it so they're
making it appealing but what if they're
just straight-up
will pay you for your DNA which I think
they kind of already do in some
instances
like a kid like this that I feel like
I'm cool like knowing my family history
and having a relatively good
understanding of like what our health
history is and like things that we
should look out for him be careful of
but like other than that I'm all set I
don't know what that kit would give me
yeah I mean mm-hmm
it's creepy give you the creeps is what
it would give you yeah well I don't like
speaking of stuff like that like I know
some of you guys like your favorite
podcasts are conspiracy theory ones and
that kind of thing goes we all like
those but like they're so hard because
the only ones to me that are like worth
talking about at all are things that are
even like mildly like they could be
possible which is why you don't see like
a thousand conspiracy videos all the
time it's like the good ones are hard to
find
yeah they're hard to find and they're
also hard to like turn into a podcast
yeah well some of them are just like
videos or like EVPs or like you know
things are you kind of have to watch and
or listen and see some of it and then
all of that stuff can be completely fake
you know so that's not necessarily a
good conspiracy theory but like but that
doesn't mean you shouldn't tweet us your
really good conspiracies that you
because the best ones we've discussed I
did see one recently this isn't a
conspiracy theory but it was a cool
theory that someone had said that
birthmarks where like I meant that you
were killed in your past life and where
your birthmark is is where you were
killed what we have one on your toe I
don't know well if you have one on your
butt yet maybe get hit by a car a
bayonet okay we don't know when you died
that's weird
that's the the with a cannon that's not
a good theory I think that's a stupid
theory you got bit by a mermaid thing is
a stupid theory because birthmarks like
what how many birthmarks all right there
how many times did I die
those are moles that's not a birthmark
birthmark is like a big one I have one
of my butt
you do yeah what you've seen my butt
I haven't seen a birth where anybody
show it show me under the table early
yeah go over there they can't see you
have hair on your butt and I'm not
staring at your butt
that's not a birthmark that's a mole no
it isn't you don't have a birthmark on
your butt just like I said no no no the
Virgo I'm right peach don't get out I'm
kidding his birth that's not I've had it
since birth it's a birthmark it's a mole
Trillian birthmark how do you
differentiate it's just like instantly
looking at it cuz it's just a mole let
me see it again
no you have to come close just show me
just come close I don't know what look
taking your pants out it's like I have
your waistline do it
you're just moaning me for the sake of
movies like those kids put their pants
and their ankles to pee at this talk no
put their pants on their ankles and pull
their shirt that's an Aries move hmm in
Aries because it's quick and it's
effective and it's messy give me a baby
girl you're else is quick and effective
is postmates some food delivered to your
house use post mates
it's the app that delivers or delivery
is not an option so if you like fast
food or if there's a local restaurant
that you really crave but you're like
dude I'm on my couch nothing is gonna
get me up not even this meal get on post
mates look and see what they have the
odds are that they will have that
restaurant and they can deliver it to
your front door for a small delivery fee
and right now you get $100 towards your
delivery credit so it won't even be a
delivery fee in the first seven days
when you use our code which is Jenna
Julianne Howe Post mates is on the
second page of my apps on my phone that
is a real fact and I use it all the time
post mates it's dude if I need basil if
I need peanuts if I need one thing I
will literally refuse to go out and I
would just postman it to my front door
so right now guys check it out just give
it a shot I've used a lot of delivery
this is by far the best one and I think
you guys already know that because I've
talked about postmates sway before we're
even sponsored by them but check it out
go to post meets on the App Store or the
Google Play Store or whatever phone you
have download the app and use code
genuine you get $100 of free delivery
credit for your first seven days cities
right there do they're there cause if
you didn't use that Post minutes you
should try checking checking yeah they
are always moving into new places
they're doing big things just so you
could eat the food that you want to eat
also guys Mandy's does your undies do
need a refresher because the odds are it
does okay you can refresh it perfectly
with a me andis membership every month
me and ease releases a new exclusive
print made in collaboration with an
artist or brand that only members can
get and with a special member pricing
you guys will also pay less for
everything on the Mandy's website so not
only will you have the consistent undies
being delivered to you and not only will
they be exclusive because you have the
membership but you will also get a
discount on anything else on the website
with that membership so if you want a
second pair of undies or bralette a
lounge pants or even some socks you'll
pay less than anybody else and the motor
ship comes with no strings attached
you can switch styles skip a month or
cancel at any time if your bum hasn't
tried Mandy's yet they are the softest
underwear in the world dude three times
off in the con you have no idea what
you're missing try it out they come with
a hundred set 100% satisfaction
guarantee if you don't love it send it
back for a full refund go to me undies
that's Emme UND IES comm slash
annejulien
to get 15% off your first parent also
guys feed your dog some high-quality
food with the farmers dog this is so
cool so what I did is like defrosting
that's why I have this towel right here
guys I went on the website
I entered all the information about our
three pets and you enter what kind of
dog they are what they generally like to
eat what their eating habits are how big
they are and basically they send you
this awesome like box filled with
individual packets like with labels for
your specific dog which dog gets what
and it's high-quality delicious food for
your dog okay
it's made fresh you keep it frozen and
then when you're ready to feed him you
defrost it and you feed him and the dogs
will lose their mind for eating peach
and Kerman right now he's Chokin
underneath the table he's so excited
this farmers dog it's just like a really
small questionnaire and they develop the
meal perfectly for your dog so you have
to know the work you'd also shop in the
pet store what kibble to get you don't
have to like try to force your dog to
eat if they're not hungry because they
don't want to eat that disgusting cable
anymore you just give them a farmer's
dog meal and they're just so excited and
they're gonna love you more guys
this is also a good way to bribe your
pet start feeding your dog better today
get 50% off your first two weeks trial
of healthy dog food at the farmer's dog
calm that's th e FA RM e RS t OG comm
slash Jenna Julian's get your 50% off
thank you sponsors thank you sponsor and
thank you sponsors for supporting us up
to two hours seriously we're so excited
when we first got our first sponsor that
was so exciting that was with Shane
right Kermit really wants that food now
they're so cute it says peaches beef
recipe hmm that's turkey recipe we had
them on like freeze-dried patties and we
would occasionally run out of dog food
and then be like super [ __ ] cuz it
would be like you know a time when we
can't just go run and get dog food like
all right what do you guys want trees
what should I make you some rice well
for real like there would be a lot of
times where like it's it's like nine
o'clock all the stores have closed and
we like didn't even think yeah about the
fund so like the fact that you can kind
of like freeze these and have them in
your freezer is nice how do you spell
this was a ke CA TsUP no I don't like
that it's not catsup right like they
have a bed like why do they both need to
be sitting in my lap cuz they're just
needy animals I really like them that
was one of my you don't get to complain
about that as you love it I think we
like roasted the dog sort of we're
really like told stories about them with
them right yeah they haven't set up here
on the new setup and we have the rack
actually they might not be able to I
liked our conspiracy theory podcasts I
put I like I'm really proud of some of
the games that we came up with and then
we played the the roulette ones are
really good yeah believe just like made
that up
click the true light is probably I think
I invented that game and I'm pretty
happy about it go
click maybe turned out really good all
of our what is it the bomb shelter ones
nuclear winter winter those are good
dude yeah we should we should put a new
twist on that and do it and do that
again
that would be fun was that the one where
one was like was it presidential
roulette because we had the four cannons
done both we've done both and then we're
like who are you gonna vote for if they
had XY and Z characteristics and Gary
Johnson kept winning and I was just like
cracking the [ __ ] up yeah that was
really fun um I know that a lot of
people just like the podcast where we
just like sit and shoot the [ __ ] and
talk I like those two I like those two
and I like I like what's come out of a
lot of this podcasts because a lot of
sometimes the conversation we have in
the podcasts where we just kind of
decide we're going to talk like becomes
for me the most stimulating to like re
watch and listen to and I think you guys
enjoy it too well yeah this is what
you're sitting you're having a
conversation you don't know where it's
going or anything you know yeah like you
just go with the flow
you just go with the flow like dude the
like like what is this it's the color
red dude how crazy is that okay you know
that's like a really good mind blowing I
think you might pull a muscle from that
reach be careful just saying it's colors
dude you know I adore Julian sucks at
celebrity trivia and music don't and TV
and movie song I don't adore that those
have all been very fun like some of my
favorite like moments where when we
figured out that you can't tell Julia
Roberts and Hathaway and Sandra Bullock
that happened on the podcasts like the
very first time that I figured out you
discover that I had that defect
I couldn't tell these people my favorite
things over but you can't tell them
apart
mmm I also appreciate the fact that
we've been able to kind of use the
podcast as a platform to talk about
issues that might not be easy to talk
about in general but also easy to talk
about like on our channels or elsewhere
like in the in the four years that we've
been having this podcast there have been
a lot of things that have happened both
in our community and just in the world
that we've been able to kind of get on
here and have a conversation about in a
in like a civil collected way
well yeah it's been and I've always said
this that has been really liberating for
me to have like a separate platform
where we can just sort of sit and talk
because in the past I would if I wanted
to say something about something like
your choices are to tweet it like that
was you know put it on Facebook or write
a whole blog post if I wanted to or make
a video and if you choose to make a
video you're still in those like you
know 2013 or 2012 confines of like it
needs to be under three minutes and it
needs to be entertaining which sucks
because you just want to voice your
opinion or have something to say you
know because you're a human being but
you you're like it needs to be funny and
entertaining which sucks cuz sometimes
you just want to say what you think but
this has given me and you the
opportunity to just you know say speak
your mind or say something that you want
to say without the pressures of it being
you know an entertaining video yeah and
it's also let me like kind of spread my
interviewing wings a little bit you're
good at even if it's just interviewing
you I'm not I'm not gonna interviewing
people it's a skill I do not is
debatable but I think it's just fun more
than anything to be able to like to talk
to someone and ask them questions that
you maybe think that they haven't
answered before in like a really like
conversational way like [ __ ] dude we
watch the challenge for how many years
and then it has a cast member on the
show yeah that was really cool it's
really cool it's cool to think back on
things like that especially Cochran like
he's a cool dude
and we'll Tech's from time to time
and we met because the podcast yeah
that's [ __ ] insane
he won survivor yeah yeah by the way
it's coming no I don't know I don't know
what there are all kids it's a survivor
kids up season coming up that's a lie
dude I just got you so bad live on the
podcast you didn't I got you it just
said no it's subscribe for more pranks I
can't legally like do that can they
really can you imagine survivor kids
they're like be more [ __ ] cutthroat
no you you cut Jared okay they they
would literally all crown the first of
course is look I don't dude if I was a
kid I would just cry for like I had to
fly in a plane and I miss my mom stupid
kids dude seriously are you sure oh I
know yeah I'm very excited I'm always
excited like John Cochran said even you
know when there's nothing on TV what did
you say was the best survivor even when
Survivor is not good it's still the best
thing on TV yeah because it's really
good with words and things and you have
your love island I love love island we
had a long conversation about that last
night I really yeah well okay so for
those of you that didn't see that which
whatever whatever you are a lot of you
guys are telling you to watch love
island and I like I really got into it
so I've watched the first two seasons
completely and then I'm like a quarter
to a third of the way into the third
season the ones that are available on
Hulu I don't know if there's like you
know a million more seasons but those
are the ones that I've been watching and
it's I just like the comparison between
that show and American reality shows is
like blatant you know like they just
have cameras up and the most
entertaining things are just people
living their lives or as an American
reality show is like so heavily focused
on the drama and the fights and like if
something epic doesn't happen you know
their scene is like a boring show or you
know what I mean
yeah and you were like you were sort of
arguing last
that despite the fact that there are
moments where I might feel like people
are just trying to be like entertaining
it on TV it is like a genuinely like
lawyers to experience watching love
island because you just you're a fly on
the wall family and I think that those
people come across as like really
genuine and they're like really a couple
or person just for those love Island
folks out there come on who's your
favorite one
give us one I really liked John and
Hannah I'm the first season you know I'm
talking ya know I like John Hannah's
here therefore that first fight they
have is a little you didn't watch any of
it you've never seen any of love island
but I'm gonna bullshitting right yeah
well someone on twitch was like general
of islands horrible like I think that it
it gives people you know an unrealistic
view of like love or relationships and
we talked about that for a little bit
because I think that that's you know not
necessarily false there are young people
like the people that they cast for the
shower between the ages of like nineteen
in like 24 you're all beautiful and
they're all incredibly beautiful and
like of course they're all probably
gonna date for a month or two and then
break up you know cuz that's like what
you do when you're 19 but like as far as
dating in reality shows go it's it's
more on the spectrum like on the side of
the spectrum where it's like really real
it's on that side of it though yeah as
far as those shows go yeah yeah it's not
you don't watch love island to get a
perfectly accurate depiction of what a
normal couple goes through or they when
they did yes for example like I like to
watch love island like when I'm doing
cardio like on the bike or something I'm
just sitting there and like chillin and
watching it so I was watching Love
Ireland at one point during the day and
then later on at night we were watching
bachelor in paradise and like the
difference between the two is ridiculous
everything's so pretty they're just like
it they're like hi oh my god walk down
to the bar and they're like having this
you know orchestrated conversation about
what's going on like everything is so
the camera is already focused on the
person reacting because
person has been told to like get up
there with them yeah or they like you
know them on love island the most that
they'll sort of like produces like
they'll have a challenge set up or
something for them or like you know they
can win a date but that's just for
content purposes yeah but it's not like
a we brought in your [ __ ] you know
yeah dude
don't even don't even when they brought
in Becca and bachelor in paradise just
to walk through the [ __ ] beaches
everyone off like what in the world well
to be fair so they do bring people's
exes in on love island but I feel like
their reactions are genuine and how they
handle everything is genuine you know
what I mean like the producers do throw
a wrench every once in a while but I
feel like for the most part it seems
like a true-to-life how someone would
handle that situation it's not this like
overblown overdramatic like everything
the world's ending you know what I mean
yeah yeah no I'm just I really like I
just live their life anything that has
to do with The Bachelor now is like I
watch that show in real we watched what
there's three seasons of it or two
seasons a bit I forget we watched
however many seasons there are and like
that show was amazing and I really
enjoyed it and it's a brilliant
television show but at the same time now
I cannot watch the bachelor or the
Bachelorette with those same
rose-colored glasses that I had on
before because now I'm just like I'm
seeing everything that's happening I'm
seeing all the strings being pulled and
I kind of [ __ ] hate it because I feel
I sort of like feel for some of the
people who are on the show most of the
people that I can you know I don't I
don't feel too much for him but you know
like um yeah like what's that couples
name Carly and Evan Carly and Evan like
close to me like I love that couple and
I love that they kind of like made it
out of that world
yeah and became a real thing but yeah
for the most part I'm just like watching
and I'm like the more miserable someone
gets are the more like and you can tell
these people like you can tell when
they're playing it up but you can also
tell when they're just like generally
like [ __ ] pissed and like not excited
to be there and like just really
regretting a lot of [ __ ] yeah yeah it
just sucks because that that's like
their ideal situation the producers
that's what they want they want these
people to be [ __ ] breaking down and I
hate them yes and I think
that's like one of the largest
differences is I feel like a love island
sort of thrives on the people are
finding love and that's what we really
want when in theory so does the bachelor
or the Bachelorette in paradise but
they're so focused on the tears the
breakdown the meltdown the the this that
everything's going wrong they they focus
on their like doom and gloom
whereas love island they really sort of
like encourage that like everybody get
along and like be friends and you know
if you can't work it out that's okay but
like people apologize to each other and
like you know make sure that they're
trying to handle the situation the best
that they can
or they'll talk to their friend and
their friends really honest with them
it's not like yeah dude let's go beat up
our house mate you know well and also
another thing is I've only watched over
the shoulder a couple episodes of love
island because I like I really haven't
spent the time no question like you have
know from what I have seen there's been
more than a handful of instances where
I'm just like watching a couple lay down
in bed and just like hanging like they
kind of want to be just doing that like
you know like say you and I met on love
island right and we have this instant
connection we've both realized right
away like this is my person whatever you
don't really care too much about the
extraneous [ __ ] going on in the house
you just want to like hang out with that
person and I see that I actually saw
that a lot on love island that's like
yeah because on like the bachelor
bachelor in paradise like they don't get
the choice to do that no right they like
they gonna have to go man someone's
comfortable with another person they
bring another person in to [ __ ]
everything up no but they're no I'm
saying they're confined to like actual
filming hours you know oh yeah yeah it's
like they have structure during the day
because very because they're filming
whereas love island there there aren't
camera people there's just cameras in
the wall so like yeah you're doing what
you would usually do with someone when
you're you like them you're just like
laying down and hanging out and like
talking so so a bachelor in paradise
like there's filming ours yeah they have
like dates you know and I mean and then
everyone else though I go downstairs
deliberately like they're not really
filming them like laying around and
doing nothing because they can't do
nothing there at work they all know that
hmm that's interesting I guess I didn't
really thought of it like that I mean I
guess it like he like you watch unreal
and you see like they they're they cut
and they're just like walking around and
I really
doing it but they have like a proper
production so like they have a camera
crew that has filming hours it's ponding
they're like filming them while they
sleep yeah I mean I don't know no you're
right
plus they can't just like hang out with
the bachelor that's the whole point
no I'm talking more about bachelor in
paradise than anything I think bachelor
has more problems but you know what I'm
trying to say yeah no I get it there are
no like production hours and like a Big
Brother house or like a love island
house whereas on a show like The
Bachelor the bachelor in paradise it's
like we're not filming you during
certain hours so that's begs a question
that's why they all wake up and they've
all got mad make up on [ __ ] they know
what time they come in so if if bachelor
in paradise or bachelor was filmed in
the Big Brother style with cameras on
the wall everywhere and there were no
real funny man you think he'd be better
or worse I think it'd be more real I
know me better cuz I prefer things that
are a little more real I think you
definitely be more real but I don't
think it would be on TV
mmm because they like that show exists
because it's like it's the most produced
thing in the world whatever I like love
Island and I want to say thank you guys
to first to Jesse not to me it's only
the best show in the whole world is
there my favorite show no no but I'm
enjoying it mm-hmm that's dope and
there's so many [ __ ] episodes yeah
you've been watching that ship for weeks
dude how many episodes are there there
was like 40 last season 40 41 hour
episodes
yeah and they're in the house for like a
couple months I think she's dude they
really show you like everything each
season is it is it new people
yeah whole entire new people uh-huh okay
so they resolve all the storylines well
so to speak relationship stories as the
season ends so you kind of see if they
stay together broke up and then I google
it after do people leave mm-hmm is that
part of it or do people just leave when
they want it's part of it yeah how what
what qualifies like getting kicked out
of the house you don't get kicked out
what is leaving what does it happen you
have to couple up but if you don't
you're gone yeah that's sad that's like
is there like cry you know
mmm are sad to leave well anyway guys
nothing
closing the episode it was fun I've
really got celebrated because I front
tries you know I do do I feel like I
celebrated a little bit maybe not as
much as I could I laugh at I'll really
celebrate when we get to 500 that's an
impressive number 200 is me I'm pretty
proud of it though
I'm not I'm proud of where we've grown
this thing I also want to say thank you
guys for continuing to hang out with us
or finding anything fun in our podcast
cuz it's like we just like to sit here
and have a good time I'm glad you guys
also have a good time you know
yeah I never would honestly I never
thought I would have a podcast and I
never thought I'd have a podcast like
this mm-hmm
where I just sit with my girlfriend and
talk and we have fun most times and we
play games and like I don't know I like
never thought that that was times I
don't know just crazy to think about man
but yeah thank you guys for supporting
us and listening to us for so many hours
that's now over roughly probably 200
hours of us ramble about nothing I ate
all my friend tries perfect honey and
you could postmates some more right now
well thank you guys for hanging out for
this podcast and 199 prior if you guys
have any dream guests of your own let us
know who knows man who freaking knows
crazier things have happened
mm-hmm or if you have any feedback of
what you'd like in the future I mean no
promises but we can try our very best
you know feedback does help and I
appreciate when you guys are
constructive with your criticism because
a lot of times well no not a lot of
times all times that you know you leave
something in the comments section we try
to do our best to listen to it and to
take it seriously and implement it
because you guys are your the lifeblood
of the episodes like you're who were
talking to so peachy we're almost done
here french fries almost done here
I am also guys let us know if there's
any sort of different
I don't know if we were to playing a
live podcast like what what you might
want for that you know whether it's like
what we have planned for it or how we do
it just know let us know because we want
to organize that at some point I'd be
fine maybe not like next week because
it's gonna involve some tweaking to our
setup
but regardless thank you guys for 200
episodes
you are wonderful dink-dink and i'll see
you next week have a good week
[Music]
[Music]